quand les physiciens parle du multivers
ils pensent généralement un ensemble de
plusieurs univers qui existeraient
vraiment dans la vraie réalité
et alors ce sont des réflexions
fascinante souvent même vertigineuse
mais elles n'ont généralement que très
peu voire aucun impact sur notre
quotidien
aujourd'hui à linverse j'aimerais vous
parler d'univers parallèles qui n'existe
pas et qui sont beaucoup moins
spectaculaire mais qui sont aussi
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
importants pour notre quotidien on va
parler de ce que l'excellent livre how
to decide de la joueuse de poker
annie duke appelle le multivers
bayésiens et de pourquoi il est crucial
en mesurer toute l'étendue et pour bien
mesurer l'immensité et l'importance de
ce multi verts parisiens
je vous propose de revenir en 2009 au
moment où l'épidémie de grippe a h1n1
menace est le monde
fin avril 2009 suite au début de
l'épidémie de grippe a h1n1 au mexique
et devant l'incertitude énorme sur la
nature du virus
sa contagiosité et sa dangerosité l' oms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
qualifie la situation d'urgence de santé
publique de portée internationale
quelques jours plus tard le 1er mai 2009
roselyne bachelot alors ministre de la
santé rapporte que deux cas de grippe a
h1n1 sont identifiés en france sur tf1
le 11 juin 2009 l' oms parle désormais
d' alerte pandémique l'organisation
déclare que la pandémie de grippe 2009 a
maintenant commencé le 30 juillet 2009
l'institut de veille sanitaire déclare
le premier décès de la grippe a h1n1 en
france le 14 septembre 2009
la préoccupation augmente alors qu'un
patient de 26 ans en bonne santé meurt à
son tour
d'autant que l'hiver approche une
période habituellement particulièrement
propice à la propagation des virus de la
grippe
dans ces circonstances la ministre de la
santé roselyne bachelot décidé
d'investir massivement dans la lutte
contre la grippe a h1n1
94 millions de doses de vaccin sont
commandés et une énorme campagne de
vaccination est mise en place en octobre
2009 pour un coût estimé à 1,5 milliard
d'euros
question roselyne bachelot at elle eu
raison d'effectuer une telle commande et
d'investir autant dans la vaccination de
masse
alors bien sûr comme pour le
19 le problème de la gestion de
l'épidémie h1n1 est en fait beaucoup
beaucoup plus complexe que le résumé
ultra bref que je viens de faire pour
bien comprendre ce qui aurait dû être
fait il faudra aussi parler bien plus en
détail de ce qu'on servait alors de la
contagiosité de la maladie de sa
dangerosité de l'efficacité des vaccins
de sa sécurité et de bien plus de choses
encore
néanmoins il est intéressant de noter
que pendant dix ans et en gros avant la
crise du comité 19
la plupart des observateurs ont jugé que
les décisions de roselyne bachelot était
mauvaise voire catastrophique
après tout la grippe a h1n1 n'était en
fait pas plus dangereuse que la grippe
saisonnière et le vaccin contre la
grippe a h1n1 une nécessité qu'une dose
au lieu des doses administrées
il y avait quelques effets secondaires
très indésirable notamment une
soixantaine de cas de narcolepsie parmi
4 millions de vaccinés mais surtout dans
le cas de h1n1
l'épidémie a disparu petit à petit à
l'entrée de l'hiver si bien que le 13
janvier 2010 la fin de l'épidémie est
officiellement déclarée en france
à ce moment là seulement 7 % de la
population ont été vaccinés et est resté
du coût 40 millions de doses pas encore
utilisé en plus des 50 millions de doses
qui n'avaient pas encore été livrés a
posteriori en janvier ou en août 2010 la
campagne de vaccination de roselyne
bachelot paraissait être un fiasco aux
yeux de beaucoup
oui mais ça c'est a posteriori le
problème c'est qu'au moment de la prise
de décision de roselyne bachelot le
futur était inconnu il n'y avait pas un
seul futur certains sur lequel l'univers
allait s'engager au moment de la prise
de décision il y avait un multi vers de
futurs possibles
en août 2009 il reste est tout à fait
possible que h1n1 deviennent extrêmement
contagieux et dangereux au coeur de
l'hiver
pire h1n1 aurait pu connaître des
mutations qui le rendent davantage
contagieux et mortel
ceci aurait pu surcharger les services
hospitaliers au caire des mesures
drastiques de confinement est paralysé
toute l'économie
telle était alors un univers futur
plausible c'était une preuve crédible du
multivers bayésiens c'est à dire du
multivers des mondes crédible sachant
les données dont on dispose
à l'instant présent cependant cette
branche du multivers bayésiens s'est
évaporée en janvier 2010 car les données
de la propagation et de la dangerosité
de h1n1 écartée désormais cet univers
alternatif mais alors au moment de faire
les bilans en janvier ou en août 2010
les critiques n'ont pas envisager
l'existence de cette branche alternative
et ils ont résonné avec l'univers qui
connaissait pas avec le multivers qui
demeurait imaginable en août 2009 en
fait en août 2010 cette branche
alternative part à ces sites distante de
la branche connu qu'elle paraissait
irréaliste voire loufoque mais dire cela
ça revient à tomber dans ce que la
joueuse de poker annie duke appelle le
biais du résultat c'est oublier que la
décision devait être prise un instant de
grande incertitude à un moment où le
multivers parisien était immense et que
de nombreuses branches très distinctes
demeurer crédible comme nous le
conseille annie duke
il faut juger le pari pas le résultat
bien sûr ce qu'on dit il à propos de
h1n1 s'applique à toutes sortes de
décisions et de critiques de décision
quand on regarde de manière
rétrospective on ne voit qu'un seul
univers bien délimitées bien connu
cependant le problème de la prise de
décision est un problème généralement
prospectifs
surtout quand il s'agit de stratégie sur
le moyen ou sur le long terme
dès lors il est critique de se rendre
compte de l'immensité du multivers
barisien et de la multitude des futures
alors crédible
malheureusement l'enseignement surtout
en sciences a tendance à être
extrêmement rétrospective
on a tendance à apprendre les résultats
des siècles d'expérimentation et
d'analysé de données qui permettent de
réduire la taille du multivers selon
certains axes pire encore on a tendance
à réduire la science à ce qui est
parfaitement connue c'est à dire à ces
parties du multivers bayésiens sur
lesquels il n'existe peu ou pas de
branches alternative mais cette habitude
à confondre savoir et certitude semble
avoir le mauvais goût de nous pousser à
sous-estimer l'ampleur du multivers
bayésiens notamment lorsqu'il s'agit de
questions plus prospective c'est à dire
qu'il concerne un futur que les données
collectées à ce jour ne permettent pas
de réduire à une branche bien connu est
délimitée en fait le multivers bayésiens
ne se limite pas au futur
tout comme le futur le passé et en
particulier le passé lointain est lui
aussi très méconnu il y a là encore
plusieurs branches multivers possible et
d'ailleurs au fur et à mesure que nous
souvenirs sont effacés
ou que des données sont perdues ce
multivers passé court aussi à son tour
et puis le multivers bayésiens il
concerne également le présent en fait
même le présent est un immense multivers
g typiquement énormément d'incertitudes
sur le nombre de cas total de kobe de
10,9
aujourd'hui un instant présent la santé
mentale global à l'heure actuelle ou
même le fait que vous êtes en train de
regarder cette vidéo ainsi dans un
bureau sur votre ordinateur ou affalé
dans votre canapé sur un téléphone le
multivers bayésiens en fait c'est la
norme
et bien souvent ce multivers est
absolument immense et ça c'est
certainement quelque chose de critiques
à garder en tête au moment de penser le
monde de prendre des décisions ou de
juger les décisions des autres dans tous
ces cas il semble critique de mesurer
l'étendue de notre ignorance
ceci dit contrairement
multivers de la physique le multivers
barisien lui n'est absolument pas
statique est même extrêmement dynamique
et il est critique de tenir compte de ce
dynamisme
en effet chaque nouvelles données
collectées coupe des branches du
multivers bayésiens si je sais que les
médecins généralistes s'oppose au vaccin
h1n1
alors il me faut couper les branches
dans lesquelles ce vaccin est
unanimement promu par eux et par voie de
conséquence les branches où le vaccin
h1n1 est rejetée par le grand public
vont alors représenté une proportion
plus grande des futurs probables
en fait ce dynamisme du multivers
bayésiens pour être qualifié de
multivers payet zients doit idéalement
obéir rigoureusement aux lois des
probabilités
ainsi si une donnée n'a qu'une chance
sur 4 d'être observés dans une branche
donné alors l'observation de cette
donnée devrait trancher de trois cas
s'être branche sis est même donnée avait
une chance deux sur trois d'être
observés dans une branche alternative
alors son observation devrait trancher
de 1/3 7 aux branches on peut en fait
utilisé ce visuel pour démontrer la
formule de paysans supposons qu
initialement la première branche avait
une épaisseur de 12 alors que la seconde
avait une épaisseur de 6 à priori avant
d'avoir observé la donne et on voit que
la première branche à deux tiers de
l'épaisseur totale ce qui correspond
donc à une probabilité égale à deux
tiers une fois coupée par quatre
l'épaisseur de la première branche n'est
alors plus que de 3
l'épaisseur de la seconde branche elle
perd un tiers de son épaisseur ce qui
lui donne une épaisseur a posteriori de
quatre voix alors qu a posteriori une
fois le multivers couper la deuxième
branche est légèrement plus épaisse que
la première la probabilité de la
première branche est alors son épaisseur
/ l'épaisseur totale de toutes les
branches restantes ce qui fait 3 7e
on vient en fait là d'appliquer ni plus
ni moins la formule 2 bis bon bien sûr
comme on l'a déjà vu en pratiques
appliquées rigoureusement la formule
buzz est extrêmement compliqué ce qui
est peut-être plus important pour nous
autres humains en pratique c'est que le
multivers bayésiens va constamment
changer après chaque nouvelle donne est
observée c'est ainsi que le multi
verbalise bien que vous avez en tête
devraient avoir beaucoup changé par
rapport à celui que vous aviez en tête
il y a un an qui est lui même très
différent de celui que roselyne bachelot
avait dans sa tête
en août 2009 en fait parce que vous
n'avez pas accès aux mêmes données que
d'autres le multivers bayésiens selon
vous peut être radicalement différent de
celui par exemple d'un épidémiologiste
qui a étudié en détail la situation du
h1n1 ou celle du co lead le multivers
bas les ja est subjectif dans le sens où
il dépend de l'observateur et même plus
précisément des données auxquelles un
observateur à axel votre multivers
bayésiens à l'instant présent n'existe
que dans votre tête
à l'instant présent il n'est même pas le
même que le multivers bayésiens dans la
tête de votre mois du passé ou dans la
tête de votre mois du futur ceci dit ce
multi vers béziers a beau être subjectif
et il a beau ne pas exister
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'est pas
utile en fait selon annie duke pour
prendre des décisions et pour juger a
discrètement les décisions des autres
raisonner avec votre multivers balayant
tout entier ou raisonnée avec les multi
verbaliser improbable que les autres ou
en tête et critique en particulier le
multivers bas les indus preneurs de
décisions qu'il s'agisse d'autrui ou
d'un mois du passé est généralement
immense surtout sur des sujets complexes
en période de grande incertitude comme
la gestion de pandémie en pleine
pandémie
et contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
croire naïvement l'immensité du
multivers bayésiens n'est pas un défaut
il s'agit d'une propriété des données
limitées auxquelles on a accès en fait
plus généralement il semble critique de
s'en rendre compte que les données
auxquelles on a accès sont toujours
limités et que sachant la finitude de
ces données le multivers bayésiens est
immense et pour se rendre compte il faut
d'abord prendre le temps de bien mesurer
l'étendue de notre ignorance